how does it feel to have covered 19
somebody had taken a scuba diving tank
while I'm underwater it turns it off
lately I was in mobile even attached I
couldn't move my head I looked out of
the corner of my eye and I saw people
falling I didn't know if it was real or
not people were seeing when I came and I
was blue I remember perfectly well that
I looked at my face and I looked like a
sewer
so I got scared I've seen death and I
wished for it they were lucky to survive
the global tally of coronavirus deaths
has already passed the mark of 120,000
in hospitals everywhere medical staff
give their all towards slowing the rise
I'm seeing young patients old patients
people of all age ranges who are just
incredibly sick and you can even hear it
now that as I'm walking through patient
rooms in the hallway you just hear
oxygen the virus has not been selective
with its targets and each case is its
own story so what exactly happens in the
body during covert 19 and are there any
long-term health effects
[Music]
these are some of the questions on which
we're going to focus on this edition of
kovat 19 special I'm Chris Coburn Berlin
it is good to have you with us now high
fever a dry cough and difficulty
breathing those are the most common
symptoms of kovat 19 some people show
mild signs of the disease other more
severe ones so let's take a look at how
long a person actually stays sick after
contracting the virus if they caught the
virus on day one they will probably be
contagious starting on day two or three
and this lasts for about two weeks
symptoms might start a little later and
might even be present when people are
not contagious anymore
on average some 14 percent of patients
with symptoms have to be admitted to
hospital for up to 20 days and half of
these hospitalized patients on average
end up in an intensive care unit now for
more let's bring in professor Klaus
hobby is a pulmonary doctor and former
president of the German respiratory
society it's good to have you on the
program
how does Kovac 19 differ from other
respiratory diseases and what does it
mean to people treating patients first
of all thank you for having me this is a
relevant question that's been asked to
doctors like me all the time
listen there are commonalities and their
differences commonalities are this is a
virus infection
it means they began to certain such as
cough such as Disney and some patients
some mild symptoms as you described in
the program there are some differences
however and that is what we've learned
we've learned that people may have
symptoms for a few days and at day six
seven eight they become severe they
develop dis Nia they develop sort of a
fatigue syndrome they develop aches and
that makes sometimes the oxygen fall it
makes these people to present with
mostly diseases when this is when
need intensive care treatment what is
the biggest problem with people that
need this intensive care treatment what
are two things obviously you need the
capacity to post them to treat them in
hospitals that we've seen the reports
from around the world shortages of
intensive care beds has been a major
shortfall in this in this discussion in
systems like ours in Germany at present
where we have enough capacity that seems
manageable although it takes a lot of
toll from the nurses and the doctors and
the intensive care units but immediate
care in intensive care with oxygen
supply with the delivery of this
property including ventilation is
something we just needed them especially
since we know we have no real treatment
available other than so the better
treatment in the kewpie city or
individual right and patients that end
up in intensive care usually need to be
ventilated at which point do you decide
to do that
well develops this form of pneumonia
which starts with an interstitial
pneumonia as we saying it in the cities
and it's it's adaptable these people
drop with the oxygen tension these
people get severe it is knowing and when
we measure the oxygen tension below a
certain level that's the time when we
realize that there's a fatigue of
respiration that people need that sort
of support these people are then put on
a ventilator in intensive care
some of people will be bridged mainly
with non-invasive ventilation to avoid
mechanical ventilation or a lot of
people end them in mechanical
ventilation and this is when they end up
in ICU this is another point that it's
making that different different we
learned with time that the duration of
the insulation these individuals is
longer than we anticipated and it takes
quite a few days until it's decided
which further thing okay and what does
it mean being ventilated for the
patient's themselves it means that
you're not conscious it means that you
are deeply sedated in an awake
that's what it's sometimes reported we
reported s you will be intubated with
the tube and the error system will be
cannulated and you will be mentholated
by a machine with a certain oxygen
delivery in a certain pressure to take
over the mechanical breathing at the
time when you not capable of saturating
your body with oxygen it's an extreme
situation it takes a lot of tall and it
is a severe state and we know from the
figures that a lot of people
unfortunately die under these conditions
mm-hmm can you tell us anything about
the long-term possible long-term impacts
to patients lungs fully recover once the
infection is over well I think that's a
very good question and we've been asked
this for for-4 many people obviously the
serum or the symptoms or the disease is
called a RDS and people probably have
seen as nervous acute respiratory
distress syndrome it means that there is
chaos if you wanted the lung there is
leakiness of the vessels and/or the
membranes of the lung there's a lot of
inflammation going on we know from the
literature from areas that a lot of
people will have follow-up the problems
with their lives they scar they will
develop some sort of what we call
fibrosis these things may last for quite
a long time once you survive them so the
research is now addressing this already
there are long-term consequences of the
lung disease but also other diseases the
heart is one of the organ system that
will also be affected so we would expect
that once people survive and intensive
care and ventilation there is a high
chance for long-term follow-up sequela
and long term follow-up complications
unfortunately closed Robin pulmonary
doctor thank you for sharing your
insights and staying with the experts
he's a biologist a science journalist
and our resident Corona expert DWS Derek
Williams and he's been answering many of
the questions you sent us about the
corona virus pandemic here's our latest
Q&A segment
can someone who has had covert 19 catch
it again there were some disquieting
reports earlier this week from South
Korea's Centers for Disease Control that
91 patients there who had code that 19
and survived it tested positive again
later for the disease the w-h-o has also
stated that it's unclear whether
recovered patients are immune that's
critical because immunity is at the
heart of strategies for combating the
virus the problem is that the body
reacts to different pathogens in
different ways sometimes with a
sustained immune response that lasts a
lifetime sometimes with one that lasts
practically no time at all so the answer
to the question of whether or a fter how
long you can be reinfected is we don't
know yet however a couple of different
studies have looked at how long the
typical immune response lasts with
related coronaviruses ones that cause
colds and they show the immune response
there remains fairly robust after a year
and studies of how long SARS and burros
patients continue to produce defensive
antibodies against those coronaviruses
seem to back that estimate up so what
experts are hoping is that infection
should provide some extent of immunity
to most people for at least a year but
it'll take time to figure out are people
with allergies like hay fever at greater
risk of contracting cope at 19 this time
of year is always tough on people with
seasonal allergies and the northern
hemisphere I should know I'm one of them
hay fever causes inflammation in your
respiratory tract and though we don't
know for sure and I couldn't find any
studies addressing this question
directly
many experts appear to think that
pre-existing
inflamation might make it easier to
catch the virus I've seen a lot of
recommendations from sources like
national associations urging people to
proactively try to keep their allergy
symptoms as much under control as
possible this year as a preventive
measure that's especially important they
say if you have allergic asthma because
asthma is a comorbidity that's
associated with worse outcomes in the
event that you do catch Cove at 19 can
you reuse disposable masks if you leave
them out for three days between wares
this is a really tough question to
answer because there's been so much
debate surrounding not only the question
of whether masks need to be worn by
everyone but also whether or not they
can actually prove dangerous if they're
not put on properly or or handled
correctly disposable masks are made to
be disposed of after a single use hence
the name the w-h-o continues to
recommend disposal after a single use
but but masks are in short supply during
the pandemic and even medical staff and
many places are having to consider
questions like whether they can be
cleaned or reused the Centers for
Disease Control in the u.s. recommends
that when there simply aren't enough
masks to go around health workers only
reuse them every five days and store the
masks after use in breathable paper bags
of course that's for trained
professionals acting in a crisis but
it's a guideline lacking others it's
what I would probably do myself but it's
really a suboptimal solution